following the sickening attack outside  liverpool women's hospital yesterday  my thoughts remain with all those  affected on on behalf of the whole  country i want to pay tribute to the  emergency services who responded as  always with such speed and  professionalism  the police have now confirmed that this  is being treated as a terrorist attack  and while the investigation continues at  pace you will understand that i can't  comment on the details of the case or  its motivation but it is a stark  reminder of the need for us all to  remain utterly vigilant  and the independent joint terrorism  analysis center jtac  are today raising the uk's threat level  from substantial to severe  meaning an attack is highly likely  but what yesterday showed above all  is that the british people will never be  cowed by terrorism we will never give in  to those who seek to divide us with  senseless acts of violence and our  freedoms and our way of life  will always prevail